how about my wife on twitch in my wife
Chin's very handsome I love my wife
she's on haulin handsome an attorney
flood see you
hey no she just said that he was very
handsome tall and handsome now Miss
Geldof Asian hey listen I don't know
what he's I can't read a woman's mind
will she like was alarmed out hey it's
not by the way might might the guy who
trained my dogs Nathan who's got his own
show on Animal Planet Marine for nine
years it couldn't be better-looking
couldn't be better looking my wife all
bright-eyed and [ __ ] bushy tails and
her friends want to come over and get
you know and didn't buy a dogs it's
ridiculous or trying to [ __ ] I'm like
I'm like hey I know a 35 and couldn't be
better looking but can you take it easy
in front of me I'm your [ __ ] husband
she's all blushy and asking him
questions I'm like you [ __ ] kidding
me right now I'm out now man a ton of
suction they went home you're avoiding
what was going on here oh I want no
Qin's drug history all right yeah that
I'm Oh what else like he's not gonna
answer dude okay here's our ecstasy
before we're never taught ecstasy I'll
answer the question yes I'll say yeah
I've tried actually before and then it
was normally like the happiest I've ever
felt
yeah from anything so were you with
girls or is like you with a whole group
of people yeah yeah I did it in San
Francisco when I was young man I
couldn't believe how cool I was I
couldn't believe I'm happy all I was we
mean how cool you were like how cool
hotel dance and I was like well I'm the
best dancer in the world and I'm in the
best place in the world and everything's
amazing and my girlfriend I were talking
about we're each other's mates we loved
each other remains yup when mates and
then at the end is the end of the night
overdub it started to wear off and I had
to I had to cross a felt rope there was
a rope that was on the ground and I just
had to step over the rope and I I was
like I can't little I cut and a guy goes
sir please step over sir please step
over sir please step over and I I was
managed to look at my girl and I went
ahh I reached my hand who's super [ __ ]
up I I don't know what happened and she
grabbed my hand and she
pulled me over and I got out of it and
then I then we had sex and it was the
best sex of all time this the other
thing and I don't know if the current
event we brought up at the live show I
see on my social media Peter uh not
disrespectful but Frank mayor's like
though shots getting paid to say Conor
McGregor oh yes my violin i I don't know
what comes I don't know who Frank Mir
sources are I think for Frank you know
he's been doing a lot of boxing lately
and I think he thinks it's crazy that I
the things I say about Conor McGregor to
say I'm getting paid or to say that
there's some sort of you know I I don't
know what that is I mean as far as is
there some sort of like it's a game to
me or something like that
listen I wish I was get enough actor to
say this and stick with it and make it
up anyone who knows me knows I'm
passionate about this I there's a reason
why I get these gigs because I'm passion
about and I believe it and I will argue
with anyone Max Kellerman Jim Lampley
Paulie Malignaggi any of those boys any
any of them I walk you to the death I
just I disagree with anything oh that's
that's some Game of Thrones mentality
like I feel like if you had a kid it
should it be Spartan you're in [ __ ]
300 your kids like what is the 8th May
like getting down get the [ __ ] out it's
go kill [ __ ] werewolf or whatever and
it's kinda not gonna stop your librarian
the werewolves are alive yeah I just
dude it's not going to stop your life
it's just gonna like you're not going to
be able to just dip out yeah I get
that's not a problem I'm a dip out kind
of guy I told them no like you're gonna
be 40 dipping out and [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna be like the old guide to bar and
was like what's the creepy old guy doing
I mean it doesn't move I just chanted
[ __ ] just and weather lender leather
leather just hot dog skin it sets down
to your boots uh-huh just oh my knife
and my knives no family I fell only fat
wallet in the back just a purple neck
you've in the Sun so man why would I be
lonely as everyone talks over they say
is lonely at the top it's not now when
you bring everyone to the table with you
it's not lonely but you're not lonely
but the difference is is
you're not a lonely guy people love to
be around you so I'm like I'll be at
like you're good my other 80 year old
friends that are still running with me
yeah psyche whose brain trauma kicks in
first its memory so your group of
friends or with or [ __ ] animal
you guys are savages right looks like
who's gonna remember who before the
brain trauma kicks in that's your bad
well the best part is we can meet each
other again like like a bro you ride
Moses you know we're in the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] right on going over over like 50
first dates of them say in the army no
problem it might be a good process but I
can't do actually